[Music]
so
what's your big goal
dream I want to be an astronaut
[Laughter]
oh my God
you're serious
okay
I wanted this for almost 30 years
every decision I've made I've made with
the Space Program in mind
who the hell are you I'm Jose Hernandez
sir I'm an engineer you're the new guy
right
that third floor men's room needs toilet
paper
going to space it's a stupid dream last
10 candidates were chosen from 12 962
applicants it's never gonna happen
those people who got into the program
what do they have
that you don't
they have skills that I don't have
it's taken them years to get where they
are
but there's no guarantee
[Music]
I know this is hard on everybody
my body hurts I can't sleep I know I can
make this work
over the last 10 years I've applied to
the Space Program 12 times and I've been
on the verge of giving up after each and
every rejection but you know what sir
here I am
so you could turn me down again but rest
assured I'll be standing here again in a
year
you grew up watching our people make
sacrifices it's on us now
the city is a superpower
this will not be your future but it will
always be your past who better to leave
this planet dive into the unknown
gonna make a farm worker
you're not crying
some dirt get into my eye
foreign